hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play paranoia
AK okay I don't think we're being chased
by a monster this time but we did wake
up after supposedly being in mr.
Miyagi's house I know that's not his
name but I can't remember his name for
the life of me so we need to try to get
out of here but I'm guessing that as
soon as I get a tea I was not ready for
that one
whoo hi stay away hahaha oh boy this is
not gonna be good okay I need to start
hiding again but this time oh if I hide
here this is where I hid before I don't
think this is gonna work
this is probably gonna kill me isn't it
yep that was a kill one I got the volume
like way louder my headphones for some
reason so those are like really loud to
me yeah I guess that's better it's
better that way for you guys is benefit
okay alright good good don't do that
alright I'm gonna do another sweep
through the house um I'll start from the
bottom right this time since I did again
that's very loud in my ears I'll start
from the bottom right and then sweep my
way to the left
hopefully I'll be able to hit what I
need to do soonish not be wandering
around forever table
god that's loud
somewhere else oh I had it it must be
one of the places in the kitchen because
I haven't gone to the kitchen yet damn
it oh man this is totally different with
the sound like way out quick so weird
and creepy
he's just literally wet
come on kitchen come on you can do it
kitten yes cupboards then I'll try the
sink and I think there's a closet in the
other room that I can try but I imagine
this is gonna take me quite a while like
the last one did ah summer so what now I
did it again Todd the commands -
sometimes they skip over where I want to
go it's not my fault I'm not bad this
game is stupid it ugly
is it okay enough that I am a mature
professional gamer I will not be swayed
by these amateur tricks I am of the
utmost quality and blah blah blah
willow valve you excuse me pardon me
those rude stay away CUA type but I'll
hide in here stop it just stop it I
didn't do anything it's not my fault
please stay away just leave me be oh all
right then
okay it's day five now we're still alive
apparently there I am it's morning
already I guess I fell asleep
and how could you fall asleep why did
Mira put me back here he didn't even say
anything I don't know
this key I forgot I found it in the well
maybe the door by the stairs you guys
have been yelling me about that door for
a while I thought I checked it before
and it was locked I guess I forgot about
it
so whatever whatever or maybe I never
checked oh my god that's lightning
outside yeah it's raining like crazy I
was like what the hell big rumble out of
nowhere that was the lightning outside
so anyway let's try it I think this is
the only door that's still locked let's
go in yeah going into the basement I
guess so Soho dark I can't see anything
it's too dangerous was there a
flashlight anywhere not that I know of
I don't recall seeing a flashlight
anywhere well I'll check around this was
just a bathroom maybe in here somewhere
um where the hell am I gonna find a
flashlight this is gonna take forever
cuz now I got to comb through the whole
damn house again like confluent
du Bois whoo I remember seeing a
flashlight anywhere what was that why is
this stuffed bear here I've already done
this maybe in the storage room upstairs
I bet there might have been something up
there but let me check just double-check
everything down here first no nothing in
here I'm thinking that's where I would
assume that it would be other than that
it might be in that living room area I
don't know let me check let me check let
me check not this one no not this one
nothing in there I'm assuming that it's
gonna be on a desk or something I really
really hope no where's that storage room
here it is okay maybe there's something
in one of these small tools cleaning
supplies damn it I was hoping I was
hoping then it's got to be lying around
in the open it's it's just got to be
that's the only it's the only possible
solution that I could think of from less
hang on let me check this one last Romeo
just in case I don't see any maybe by
the bed
rows are empty contraceptives just in
case I bring mr. Miyagi over here once I
take care of the monster okay there
wasn't anything there was there any in
the bedroom nope no nope dammit dammit
dammit dammit dammit dammit dammit
dammit dammit dammit it's pretty dirty
nothing inside stupid sink
dammit dammit dammit dammit dammit oh
gosh like now you look around the room
at the basement did I find that before
did I check that ever I don't think I
ever checked that okay let's say before
we go in the basement alright we're good
we're good let's do this let's do this
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah that's very
flashlight II that creepy doll hard to
believe it's handmade the small stuff
bear doll made of felt feels good to the
touch and a big old stuff sheep lejano
aa stuffed boner large bear and a
stuffed black cat found stuffed dog
assorted colors yellow stuffed dog
anything crazy happening here something
that rabbit array but gives me the
heebie-jeebies bunny with a weird design
yeah no kidding set of three chicks
great I've checked us about everything
here I'll say anything of use wait was
this writing on the wall what does it
say it's hard to see in the dark 2 4 3 6
some kind of code
2 4 3 6 I'm right out right all right
2 4 3 6 go to go to the computer room
alright alright alright gonna learn to
die go learn tonight
I've just been obsessed with Karen hard
lately two four three six two four three
six two four three six two four three
six Bob there's only one file diary here
I've visited the gynecologist today the
doctor smiled wide and said the
infertility treatment must have worked
apparently I'm two months pregnant I was
so happy I absent-mindedly called him
during work thankfully he was just as
glad I should contact my sister soon too
I went to my sister's and told her the
news as expected she looked displeased
she accused me of having kids just so my
rich husband wouldn't run away I'm not
sure when my sister came to despise me
it must have been mom and dad's death
and to think I'm more grateful to her
for raising me than anyone I left my
sister's house being effectively driven
out but little Mickey came up to me and
whispered Congrats I've been making lots
of stuffed animals lately I'm also
making clothes for the baby I want to
meet them soon if the baby's a boy he
might not want the stuffed animals I
could give them to the kids in the
neighborhood instead I hadn't felt
anything for a while the baby wasn't
moving anymore
I never heard its first cry he was a boy
that just looked looked just like his
father
there was a Funeral and Cremation I'm
scared to talk to him I'm terrified of
being abused as a killer
my sister laughed at me over the phone
well good a shamelessly optimistic girl
like you couldn't be a mother anyhow he
left he couldn't move on with me he said
he wanted to raise a happy family so he
left all I have left is the house the
neighbors are spreading rumors about me
that I'm a killer even the newspaper on
TV says I am so do the stuffed animals
I'm selling everyone hates me
I'm scared everyone around me hates me
everyone's out to kill me I have to lock
everything in hide the keys or it can't
feel safe I talked to my sister and she
called me crazy a crazy who should die
even Mickey told me to die I think I
should die - I don't think Mickey told
you to die I jumped off the second floor
and broke my leg I was taken by the
people in blue and confined by the
people in white today I'm finally free
from the white building now's my only
chance if I'm too slow I'll be
again I just need to find the rope in
the storehouse well that's sad auntie
can I save or is a monster I never
wanted you to die no one ever said that
auntie
okay that's not good
stop it nature shut up nature shut up
crap well okay I know it's best I know
what's best
okay doing so now it's a lie it's a
dirty dirty lie I'll kill you I'll kill
all of you
hello mr. Miura
hello mr. Nakamura so how goes it
nothing happened I presume under nah you
don't believe me huh huh I'm not really
surprised that you don't believe me but
my eye oh but still why would you be so
awful as to take me back here in my
sleep mysticum aura tell me if I'm a
bother you could just tell me but this
is just too cruel inside you're laughing
at me for saying weird things because
I'm depressed and you can't pretend to
be helpful me miss Kimora calm down I
have no idea what what are you still
making fun of me calm down please
didn't you tell me you were going home
yourself last night uh oh oh don't you
remember you woke me up in the night and
said you'd be fine uh oh
I like how he just stands up on the
couch like that this isn't good MA
miss Nakamura what's the matter who do
you need to use the toilet
I'll be fine
now ah go back home that was rather
sudden it's late at night you should
stay even if it's just across the street
it's fine after all it is my house
dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun
goodbye forever
are you sure even though you're already
gone well if you say so yourself
I think I'm eating close to the end here
if I'm not mistaken it's bound to be
that can't be I didn't do that I was
sleeping all last night dr. Tom miss
tock amaura there's something I wish to
say about this mother monster in these
events what is it I don't think that
you're lying mr. Kimura whew however if
you were being chased by a monster there
would be traces of it as well as the
hair I found nothing of the sort when I
looked around I also checked the well
there was no hole or cave as you said
there was wha what it's true I'm not
lying so I was thinking could the
monster you saw in the events that occur
no be hallucinations or delusions no
hallucinations delusions what does your
depression come from and maybe your
mother's hysteria perhaps stress at work
hi wait a minute process guild regard
with guilt regarded with mr. Seki mr.
Saki became mentally ill from the guilt
of losing her child she began to hear
and see thing
perhaps you are the same way no wracked
with guilt you couldn't save mr. psyche
no and thus you see throwing things no
to lie that's not right
it wasn't hallucinations I couldn't
think but is there any other explanation
if you really are hallucinating you need
to go to the hospital not to disturb you
but if I just don't want you to end up
like Miss ie key did lies please leave
I'll just I'll handle it myself miss
Nakamura tell me please what do you what
do you really think there's really a
monster I can't even consider that it's
just a fantasy no way I know don't say
that if you haven't seen it yourself it
it really is a monster sure it is crazy
here's your psycho just like me get out
get out no I don't want to see you were
anybody just stay away excuse me if
anything happens I'll come running a
dead thing is no hallucination it
definitely exists no thank you to lie
alright final answer well then I'm going
straight to the basement why I got this
firefight in the first place you shut up
you shut up mom inside you hello
Miki are you ok screw you mom what was
that last call about what happened hmm
Miki what is it are you crying yeah I
mean no mom help me please as a monster
in this house it trying to kill me
you're the only one I can ask help me
please come get me I want to go home ha
ha
ah mom I just knew you were crazy just
like she was having all these delusions
Moo mom I always thought you were like
her so we can fantasizing and you end up
being crazy - don't call me a gun I
don't want anything to do with crazies
go hang yourself like she did hmm
how dare she she won't believe me but
it's true I'm I'm not crazy wait hang on
don't wait what wait a minute Oh day 500
kd5 I think I'm close to the end so I'm
gonna do this all in this part what I'm
going to bed
really I'm going to bed ooh I hear
something is that the monster where's it
coming from
I don't know I'm gonna say that's what
I'm gonna do I'm going down to the
basement I guess saving every slot just
keep saving save save save save okay I
think that's enough saves into the
basement at night hello oh I thought the
noise would be coming down here
definitely you kidding me right
I thought the noise would be from down
here okay
whereas the noise coming from then where
is it coming from outside the well no
it's definitely from inside the house
but where I have no sense of direction
sound like someone's crying or something
horrible I don't like it oh I gotta find
where she hung herself that's right
where did she hang herself I have no
idea okay not in here in the piano room
maybe now probably not the piano room
must have been one of the upstairs room
the blood the blood spot of course
that's where she hung herself
I took me a while to get it get me I
it's oh oh no come on come on get out of
here one shot one shot got a run have to
hide ah how's ghosts those too close
okay I'm gonna hide I don't know what ha
I was gonna try the basement
is there even a hiding spot in the
basement I have no idea this seems like
the only logical place said it would
want me to go hang on they need to like
do something here okay there we go
okay I mean that seems like the end
result of all this madness would be in
the basement right or maybe I'm just
leading it to kill me
oh I'm not I'm not moving anymore all
right
there's nowhere to hide oh okay Oh
Oh No thank you oh hi Heather
no stay back
I can't move stay away teddy bear Oh
bear what Mickey that's my name me what
aah aah
the this stuffed bear I'm so confused
what why do you keep reporting every
little thing to me I don't care about
your child I'm sorry sister I just I
want to tell someone so who else would I
my child seems quite healthy it's with
lather late birth so I was anxious how
it might go but hmm you're you love to
boast don't you about how you married a
rich man and live in such harmony unlike
you I'm a very busy woman don't bother
me with your nonsense she's kind of a
[ __ ] okay so this is a flashback weird
time to have a flashback
auntie Oh Mickey it's been a while
you're done with school for today yeah
is your baby gonna be a girl
well I don't know yet I get the feeling
it will be so I'm making lots of stuffed
animals know if it's a boy maybe you
won't care much for him I don't think so
if you made them auntie I think
anybody'd like them is that so
ah thank you I know I'll make a stuffed
animal for you too Mickey ah but you are
in high school so maybe you're a bit old
no no I'd love to have that auntie would
you really
absolutely I'll make you a cute one look
forward to it oh but if mom found out I
think she'd be really mad
it'll be fine I'm sure she'll accept my
present to my lovely niece thanks auntie
okay how about that horrible monster
that was just like inches from my face
that one that one right there that's
right this stuff bear was from my auntie
to me I was looking forward to it but
not long after auntie's child died okay
auntie I'm sorry when you were suffering
most I didn't help you
I was scared of mother I let you die
auntie but but I always loved you auntie
I wanted to meet your child and once you
finish this bear I was gonna cherish it
I even became a writer because you loved
books and taught me about so many don't
cry auntie it was rough for you it must
have hurt
you hate me don't you are you mad that I
let you die I'd for you auntie I'd do
anything
ah I love you oh goodness
auntie
Murrah mr. Kimura huh what what mr.
Miyagi whoa mr. Daaga Mario thank
goodness you've come too sorry I was so
worried you didn't answer the doorbell
so I came down here how'd you know I was
down here an ambulance will be here soon
I'm so glad you came to I shook you but
you wouldn't wake mr. Kumar are you
crying
I remembered I forgot so much but I
remember someone very important
I was weak I couldn't do anything so I
couldn't help her but I did love her I'm
very glad so I'll be fine now I
remembered that even I even I could be
loved
since then strange things stopped
happening in the house I was examined in
the hospital and they discovered I
showed signs of schizophrenia
I still don't know if there was real or
a hallucination but now I don't really
care which it was
Oh righty okay don't think I forgot
anything
bing-bong hello mr. Miyagi won't you
come in mr. Mira what is it uh I heard
you were leaving so I came to see you
off you're going back to your parents
the situation sounded complicated yes
I'll be going to the hospital often and
there's a kind of doctrine you're there
I want to get better with my mom her
hysteria is getting worse she needs to
get counseling I see what ah well it
seems unfortunate we're saying farewell
so soon
don't worry once mom and I are doing
better I'll come back here for sure
really yeah it sounds my aunty left me
I'd love to live here if I could I
wouldn't so I see I'm glad I'll Drive
you to the station now many taxis come
out here thanks a lot that would be
great
I'll be back soon aunty
uh-huh okay that's the end of the game
all right then well that was interesting
haha that was definitely all right hey
well let me compile my thoughts about
all that was an interesting ending I was
expecting something a bit more horrific
I mean I kind of pieced together there
was probably aunt chasing her throughout
the house but now even I can't tell if
it was all oh that was the good ending
oh okay
so apparently there's a bad ending which
I'm imagining psycho crazy bonkers and
being like dude a muncher believe me mr.
Miyagi huh being dragged away to the
hospital so not freaky good story though
I mean a very interesting story was very
dialog heavy this one I mean
exceptionally dialog heavy where at
least in the witch's house or like the
story gets pieced together through the
diary and everything else was kind of
secondary I mean this was exceptionally
different from the witch's house
considering the witch's house had tons
of jump scares and really cool
interesting set pieces and this was kind
of all in the same house and the key
system got tiring after a while but it
still wasn't a bad game I mean there's
nothing wrong with the game having more
story and more dialogue like that it's
just maybe could have been more
interesting to play if they had short it
up a little bit but it's more about the
experience than anything none the
scariest ever but pretty creepy most of
the time so I hope you enjoyed it
um if you got the next one that you want
me to play write it in the comments
below so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
ah
there's no world
now